this is a short video it took recently
when I went to visit Elizabeth van
valkenburg at the University of
Washington in Seattle she took me on a
tour of the greenhouse there to show me
a few examples of plant behavior
including venus flytraps and mimosa
plans yeah that's got to be hidden that
trigger don't you think one two there
are these hairs on the upper surface
there not many of them and each hair is
thing on top of some balloon like cells
so when the hair is deformed it'll
squish some of those balloon life cells
and that will cause a calcium pulse to
go into those cells that sets off the
electric signal electric signal is going
to move across to the vein and then
there's some results literature
suggesting net on the back of the leaf
you get a rapid growth on the outside
and a shrinking on the inside and that's
what causes the pattern close up
so they're feeling the touch on the
blade and some little signal to the
joint feeding baby in stem and then
folding it up so at the bottom of each
one of these blaze is a little bulb and
it shrinks on the top and swells on the
bottom and makes the leaf photo and
we've been doing experiments with these
plants if you sort of hit them routinely
like Wallace every minute for 30 minutes
and then stop but during that 30 minutes
they say oh enough of this is boring and
they open back up again and then when
you come back and hit them again they
remember that you were torturing them
and they don't respond or you can figure
out what the refractory time is when
they're able to respond again so they
are definitely monitoring and the reason
the students started doing that
experiment is she thought well if it's
raining they're going to be eating all
the time so they shouldn't just blows up
they should open back up and that's what
they have been looking at so the student
working on it now wants to know what is
the chemical memory that the plant has
in it that tells it to open back up even
one speech yet